Queremos factorizar,
"t" cuadrada menos 2t menos 15
y seguramente me vas a decir
que factorizar esto es muy sencillo
pero, en esta ocasión
yo quiero ver la factorización por agrupación
que tampoco es tan difícil, lo único que hay que hacer es aplicar
todo lo que ya sabemos.
"t" cuadrada -2t menos 15,
y lo primero que me voy a fijar
es en 2 números que multiplicados
me den -15,
recuerda que nos fijamos
en la multiplicación del coeficiente
que está al lado de la "t" cuadrada
y del término libre 1 por  -15,
me da -15 ,
entonces voy a buscar 2 números
que multiplicados me den -15,
y a su vez estos mismos números
cumplan que la suma de ellos me de -2,
es decir,
este término que tengo aquí,
el coeficiente
que está al lado de la "t",
entonces "a" más "b"
tiene que ser igual a -2
y bueno,
para esto lo primero que quiero que veas
es que tenemos una multiplicación,
que me tiene que dar de resultado un número negativo,
por lo tanto,
uno de estos dos valores tiene que ser positivo,
y el otro tiene que ser negativo.
Mientras que por otra parte,
la suma de ellos me tienen que dar -2.
Así que voy a agarrarme
los factores del 15
para ver en qué descomposición del 15
puedo obtener 2 números que me cumplan
ambas igualdades.
Así que empecemos, tomemos el 1 y el -15
que es una descomposición del 15,
ambos son factores del 15
pues 1 por -15 me da -15,
sin embargo cuando
yo lo sumo me va a dar
1-15 es lo mismo que -14,
y por lo tanto no me sirve.
- 1 y 15... -1 y 15
me da su suma 14
por lo tanto, tampoco es -2
y no me sirve,
a ver
¿qué pasa si tomo 3 y 5?
3 por -5
me da - 15
y 3 -5 me da -2
¿y qué crees?
Estos dos valores me cumplen
mis dos ecuaciones simultáneas por lo tanto,
estos son los dos números
que estoy buscando,
3 y -5,
porque 3 y -5
me suman -2,
3 por menos 5
me da -15
y 3 -5 me da -2
y perfecto,
ya que encontré estos dos valores,
ahora lo que voy a hacer es escribir este trinomio
que quiero factorizar de la siguiente manera,
en lugar de poner -2t  voy a escribir,
3t menos 5t,
así que
déjame reescribir todo esto.
Tengo "t" cuadrada en primer lugar
y hasta el final tengo -15
y aquí en medio tengo que escribir -2t
pero lo voy a escribir de la siguiente manera,
lo voy a escribir como más 3t...
más 3t
y después -5t
3t menos 5t
porque 3t menos 5t
me dan -2t
y este trinomio sigue intacto,
solamente que ahora voy a factorizar esto
por agrupación
y para ello lo primero que necesito es tomarme
la primera pareja de términos que tengo aquí
y factorizar lo más que se pueda,
y después tomarme la siguiente pareja
de términos que tengo aquí
y factorizar también
lo más que se pueda.
Más 3t menos 5t me da -2t
y entonces vamos a factorizar,
¿Y qué me va a quedar?
vueno déjenme agarrar otro color...
y voy a decir que voy
a factorizar primero estos 2... estos 2
y después voy a factorizar
los siguientes dos,
de estos 2 voy a factorizar
lo más que se pueda,
y si te das cuenta
lo más que se puede es "t"
"t" que multiplica a
"t" más 3,
"t" por "t" me da "t" cuadrada
y "t" por más 3 me da más 3t,
y a continuación me voy a tomar
los siguientes 2 términos que tengo aquí,
y de aquí voy a factorizar
lo más que se pueda.
Y si te das cuenta,
lo más que se puede es un -5,
-5 que multiplica a,
bueno,
-5t entre -5 me da "t",
entonces tengo que escribir "t"
y después -15 entre -5
es menos entre menos me da más,
15 entre 5 me da 3,
y entonces le sumo 3,
perfecto,
ya tengo esta expresión que tengo aquí.
Y ahora quiero que te des cuenta
que tengo al "t" más 3
como factor común,
tengo "t" más 3 que va a multiplicar tanto a esta parte, como a esta parte.
"t" más 3 está en ambos sumando,
por lo tanto
voy a escribir esta expresión
como "t" más 3
que va a multiplicar...
bueno,
en primera parte va a multiplicar a "t"
y después va a multiplicar a -5,
date cuenta que el "t" más 3
es un factor común
que a su vez multiplica a "t"
y a su vez multiplica -5
entonces me queda "t" más 3,
que multiplica a "t"menos 5
y ahora cierro el paréntesis,
y ya con  esto tengo
la factorización de esta expresión
fíjate que "t" más 3
es este que está aquí,
y en el siguiente paréntesis está "t" sale
de esta "t" que tengo aquí,
y este -5 sale de este -5
que está aquí.
Por lo tanto ya tengo una factorización
de esta expresión que yo tengo aquí arriba,
que era "t" cuadrada -2t menos15,
como "t" más 3 por "t" menos 5
y en esa ocasión lo hice
utilizando las mismas propiedades
de la factorización por agrupación,
al final en este caso no teníamos
un número al lado de la "t" cuadrada,
sin embargo pudimos utilizar
el mismo procedimiento,
para obtener esta misma factorización.
Nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo